[Musique]
ça y'est série lancée en deuil et normal
quand on a une saison 10 amis monsieur
trop haut
vous connaissez certainement le dicton
passé 60 ans quand on se réveille sans
avoir mal quelque part c'est qu'on est
mort eh bien c'est la raison pour
laquelle
il est intéressant d'avoir des petits
bobos et ça c'est rassurant si 144e
journal de bord mais jean marie le pen
dans le
chercher
merci jean marie le pen vous avez beau
le nier
avec sourire parce que c'est l'une de
vos forces c'est d'essayer au maire
sourire et à ses dérives et ses deux
maîtres du sourire dans les horreurs que
vous racontez
sourire dans les questions que vous
racontez nous la question n'est pas
seulement celle de la ceni à la question
je n'ai pas entendu
[Applaudissements]
on est obsédé par soi même je connais
pas beaucoup de gens qui se sent qu'ici
dilemme ouais si la part des concurrents
fait en général quel crétin qui skiff
qui ceux sur qui met sur sa bizarre
qu'on n'est pas un juste milieu en skiff
mais sur les réseaux sociaux quand on
transforme la réalité et xavier filtre
voilà elon musk a t-il un soudain
chinois des syndics fait
difficile de répondre à cette question
que se posent des internautes du monde
entier après avoir vu cette vidéo
publiée sur un réseau social en chine
d'autant qu'il ya des précédents combien
ont cru à tort que jason statham s'était
mis au challenge de danse ou qu'il
s'agissait réellement de tom cruise dans
ces vidéos truquées de manière ultra
réaliste
just wait d'un côté ça s'est arrangé
mais de l'autre côté entre cette
nouvelle cette téléréalité qui propose
des filles déjà handicapé les dubaï earl
complètement refaite alors l acceptation
de soi elle s'enfuit encore plus loin je
trouve je préfère vous prévenir ne vous
inquiétez pas si le père noël est un peu
en retard cette année c'est juste qu'il
est bloqué chez kim boulot
[Musique]
il va être en forme pendant ce temps là
thomas sotto s'échauffent l'équipe est
en forme et moi je suis imperturbable
voilà c'est comme les chats vous savez
j'en ai petits moments de folie est un
moment de la journée thomas c'est le
matin
à l'esa
[Musique]
le problème c'est qu avez-vous
évidemment le racisme les migrations
s'est quasiment votino à l'afp eric
genest voyons bah voyons bah oui bah
voyons un petit ben voyons on va les
compter ce soir abbaoui gallet vous ça
c'est quand vous n'êtes pas quoi dire il
ya le petit ben voyons non écoutez aller
la laïcité est le meilleur du temps j'ai
loupé les alerter à leur parler comme ça
ok je vous parle comme je veux on en est
pas encore président et quand bien même
vous le sauriez je vous parle maintenant
comme je veux moi au pm ripa agressé
comme ça c'est dit
ils ont envahi les rues de nos villes
trois lettres sur leur devanture c'est
bête
dubuc à mincir en garde à
icade pour va
mais je vais faire un petit
comme un petit peu d'échantillons pour
les percuter donc
et on va goûter ce animaux
après le repas après le repas
vous allez faire une journée cbd en
famille oui en famille
vous dites que c'est plus simple d'être
en bon père et un bon mari ouais parce
que j'ai fait une petite boulette avec
conjugale ça aussi j'en parle ouais bah
c'est plus facile d'être un bon père
c'est une citation de xavier dupont de
ligonnès
toi on fait un noël sans enfant c'est
bon pour pouvoir d'achat parce que c'est
quand même la chair les enfants il reste
à la maison et tu fais la [ __ ] la
bamboche les adultes puis la pala dira
j'ai mal au ventre et quand est-ce
qu'ils allaient cadeau à
18h et je suis ton bien sur la moquette
la bûche entend prendre une cuite
[Musique]
a
les dents
longues et social endss
[Musique]
67% des français estiment que le grand
remplacement est en train d'avoir lieu
70 % des français estiment je ferai
savoir on me demande des français soit
sur l'ir pour 70% soit 10% des puissants
d'empêcher tout dire je vous prends des
sons à 70 % des français disent qu'il
peut leur chaîne préférée certes ils la
regardent pas pour autant voilà à
tellement voilà donc faut arrêter non
mais c'est vrai dans quelques jours par
le rapport s comme mais non ils jouent
le dit eric
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hall appareils en sa qualité
par moderne pas si l'epa swagg man flow
série et je peux sentir moi je peux voir
à quoi ça ressemble par exemple si je
regarde ça ça c'est la paix rhdp l'aise
je me lève tôt je connais pas
ah oui c'est un peu mentaux les
herbacées ça pique un peu le nez c'est
parce qu'elle est fraîche
ok d'accord si vous me dites que c'est
de la france
tandis que vous avez mal traités alors
j'aurais aimé que ce sujet soit bon gré
mal gré de femmes qui ont dit que vous
les avez mal à passer maintenant pour
voir les accusations c'est ouais c'est
clair mais sûrement bien en parler de
votre cas on va on va en parler de votre
apport les tout jeunes à petit pas dans
un ciel et vous avez un bon et alors moi
je suis député qu'est ce que tu as
raconté
on va y aller
combien attendez on est dans le
débogueur de 10 entrées pompiers mais on
fait tout eu les boules carrées dit un
truc
pareil qu'un litre on vient nous dire
qu'on était dans sa traque des
comprendraient pas notre haine plus de
temps sur des missions spécifiques à
très longues au dessus sur place et je
veux rentrer dans votre jusque là
seulement pas je peux continuer
longtemps comme vous vous êtes capable
d'interviewer le président la république
et de fait rire des millions de
personnes
vraiment imbuvable excécrable excécrable
ça marche
révélations le petit cul c'est ce que
mariah va manger à noël ce sera ni de la
dinde ni de la bûche non pour maria ce
sera ça
[Musique]
m'a mis là même un big mac mariah carey
pour le réveillon
[Musique]
joyeuses fêtes sur france télévisions